design is subjective. there's just no way of
getting around that fact. and architecture in
a lot of ways is the art of convincing people that
your design moves were the right moves. and one of
the ways you can convince people is through case
studies. i think of case studies like a shield.
if you present it correctly, it can be a very
powerful way for you to defend your design moves,
especially if you're choosing a project that's
been successful before and it's been done by a
well-known architect. it can build a very solid
foundation for you to build your design strategies
from, and it can be a lot harder to poke holes
at something that's been proven to be successful
before. there is a lot of information out there on
how to do case studies but not so much on how to
present them. so if you're looking for information
on how to do them this is not the video for you.
in this video, i'm gonna show you how to
present them in a way that's informative,
in a way that's engaging, and in a way that can
create a bulletproof defense for your project.
hey guys, how's it going my name is dami and i'm
an architect based in vancouver. on this channel,
i make videos about architecture, design, and
creativity. one of the reasons i started this
youtube channel is because i miss the presentation
and storytelling aspect of architecture school
and so this is a process that i love and it's
a process that i'm always trying to refine
but this is a fun topic for me. so
when i started architecture school,
i was absolutely terrible at presentations.
i would get stage fright i would get nervous,
i would shake, i could hear my heartbeat, and of
course, i would work right up to the presentation.
i would have pulled like two all-nighters before.
i would basically wing it every single time,
so as you can imagine they did not go very
well. it wasn't well into my second year
of architecture school that i sort of started to
get the hang of it. i think it was a combination
of like actually liking my project and being proud
of them, and wanting to tell a story that kind
of did it justice, and also getting a little
bit better at time management so that i could
plan out my presentations beforehand. so
slowly and slowly i started to improve but
it was actually in my thesis year when i really
started to strategize on my presentation technique
and sort of build a system around it. so this is a
strategy that i've refined over years and years of
presenting my own work and from observing other
people present. nobody actually taught me this
so it is a little bit different from the
standard way of presenting your case studies
but throughout my bachelor's and my master's i did
receive numerous awards for my project and for my
thesis i received the aia henry adams award which
is the highest honor you can get for your thesis
project in north america, and i attribute this
a lot to my presentation methods. just before
we start let's just cover the basics. what are
case studies? case studies are when you study an
existing building or an existing project usually
a well-known piece of architecture to inform your
design. if you want to design a chicken coop you
don't really want to start from scratch. you want
to see how other people have done it, you want to
see how other people located their chicken coops,
how they shaped it how they place the doors
and you want to learn from their mistakes
and you want to use that to inform your design.
a lot of times students present case studies
as a formality because it's a requirement but that
is such a missed opportunity. you are using your
precious minutes of your presentation time to
talk about someone else's building, so you want to
use that to prepare the viewers for what
they're about to see with your design. so
how do you present case studies? so i like to
call the strategy sam. simplify and multiply.
so first simplify. so presenting a case study
is very different from doing a case study.
when you're doing a case study you might learn a
lot of different things from it but when you're
presenting it you just want to show the aspect
that you're going to be employing in your design
and then you want to diagram.
graphics and visual continuity is key.
you want to take the plan elevation in
section and you want to diagram on top of it.
and multiply. instead of just studying one
or two buildings, do multiple. so i read an
article a long time ago about why architectural
research is so slow to progress compared to other
disciplines like science or medicine and
apparently it's because we usually tend to
create a unique one-off solution to the design
as opposed to collecting a massive sample of
architecture and creating statistics. i mean this
is the fundamental tool behind scientific research
like they take a massive sample and then
they make some assumptions based on that.
and so we want to do the same thing. we
want to study a bunch of different buildings
and we want to show, hey, look, like all of
these different buildings achieve the thing
that i want to achieve by doing it this way, and
you want to show that you have that understanding,
especially if you want to deviate from that
and come up with your unique solution. i mean,
if you just show one or two case studies
no matter how successful that project is,
it's not really a good defense for your case
because you know those buildings could have had
really unique conditions. like they could have
had a really unique site or a program right?
so it's not really a good basis to build your
design off of. and just one more thing before
we jump into the example. the common advice is to
study a building that has the same function as the
function that you want to do in your project but
in my humble opinion that is not always necessary
because most architecture is a unique response
to a site or program and you want to create your
unique response. so i wouldn't really base it
on the function or the program but i would base
it on the feeling or the atmosphere or the way you
want people to behave in that particular space and
i would try to emulate those in your design.
i'll kind of show you what i mean in a sec
just. a little background. my thesis project was
called a library of the mind, explorations on
slow reading browsing and serendipity. and i was
looking at our culture of speed and productivity,
and how that has affected our culture of learning.
this has also had a pretty big impact in our
building typologies in our libraries, where
we went from quiet reading rooms to large
collaborative working spaces. and so the physical
thing that i created was a library in venice
and through the project it was a discourse
on all these different aspects like learning,
innovation, serendipity. so this is
the first page of the case study page
and as you can see, i'm not showing the
buildings as a main focus of the page.
the title of this page is visual harmony and
moment of pause, so you can see here i've given
three examples of buildings that have achieved
visual harmony through the use of proportions.
so as you go through these projects you can give
a little spiel about the significance of each
project but the idea is that the visuals,
it speaks for itself and um it's very easy
to convey these architectural elements without
you having to say a bunch of things about it.
so just be strategic based on how much
time you're given for the presentation.
if you're only given 15 minutes you kind of want
to breeze through this. if you have like half an
hour then you can go a little bit more in depth
into each building. and in most cases the case
studies that you'll be doing are buildings
that like your peers and your professors
will know about um because you are speaking to an
architectural audience. um so like you shouldn't
have to go too much in depth in describing like
the particular significance of each building. you
just want to distill the qualities of that
space that you're taking into your design.
the second one is rhythm and movement which is
important in slowing us down psychologically and
physically before we enter our reading space.
and so i'm showing how these two examples
are doing that. the first one through a series
of arcades and then in exeter library through a
series of colonnades, and the third one is about
nestling. which is um all about the architecture
itself creating an enclosure around your body
so that you can sit comfortably and read your
books. and then the next one is narrative sequence
which is creating special memorable moments in the
space through distinct architectural elements and
then we have degrees of privacy slash intimacy.
and i'm showing how these three buildings uh have
created a buffer between the outside world and
this intimate space of reading, both physically
and psychologically and then the last one
is the design of the stacks and browsing,
which i talk about as an important feature
in creating serendipitous discoveries. and then
once you go into showing your project you can
use the same graphics into your building. so i'll
show you an example here. so this is the pathway
approaching my building so this labyrinthian
pathway and you get into this narrow low dark
corridor and bam you come into this open grand
courtyard and you see here i'm using the same
graphics i was using in my case study. and
if you want to reinforce it a little bit more
on the next page you can show the visuals that
you were showing in your case study on the sides.
i typically try to create visual continuity so
i'll have the same graphics here and here but
i'll just change the color of the background just
so that like i'm switching back and forth between
my design and the explanation of my design and
you really have to do this for like a split
second throughout your presentation just so that
your audience understands okay like i understand
where that architectural element is coming
from. and then again back to your building
you circulate around the courtyard through a
series of rhythmic colonnades to slow us down
psychologically and physically before we get
into the library. and then the next page i have
the same graphics as i had in the case studies and
then on the next page i'll show a render and i'll
just keep doing this throughout the presentation.
and so as you go through your presentation you're
reinforcing the reason why you made certain
design moves and at the end of your presentation
um you can really focus on um
discussing your ideas not like
oh why did you do this like why didn't you do
this and hopefully it opens up the room for
um a more open discussion rather than like
a critique on your design and if it is
more of a direct critique then you are able to
speak more intelligibly about your design moves.
um which is really the point you want to get
to. so i hope you guys found this helpful um
and if you have any questions just
let me know if you enjoy this video,
i think you will also enjoy one of my other videos
where i do a quick architectural design process
from beginning to the end and in that video
you can also see me attempt to do a headstand.
aah you